régis le sommier on vous retrouve donc
pour analyser et prendre un petit peu de
hauteur sur cette rencontre rare
rencontre d'ailleurs en tête à tête
entre mais les deux hommes avec
évidemment on imagine aussi quelques
messages envoyés au reste du monde alors
oui évidemment rencontrera oui cessé de
nous être le troisième je pense
déplaceront de bachar el assad a à
moscou donc faut l'organiser c'est
quelque chose qui est qui est pas simple
pour pour ce qu'on te lances qu'on peut
en dire effectivement dans l'idée du
message au reste du monde il vient de se
passer le retrait dont on vient de
parler des américains en afghanistan et
le président russe et le président
syrien veulent la tenue est affiché eux
au contraire l'idée qu' ils ont réussi à
vaincre les djihadistes en syrie qu'ils
ont coopéré que leur armée encore opéré
depuis septembre 2015 et que aujourd'hui
en syrie en gros globalement le comment
les armées syrienne ont gagné la guerre
et et qu' il reste effectivement des
poches résiduelles de notamment dans la
province d'idlib qui encore tenues par
des groupes djihadistes mais si vous
voulez par rapport à ce qu'a montré
l'amérique qui rend les clés aux
talibans de carhaix groupe jihadiste sur
tout un territoire comme l'afghanistan
c'est évident que en comme en
contrepoint cette rencontre était là
pour affirmer affirmé que comment
poutine et hassad eux avaient réussi à
détruire les terroristes dans leur zone
d'influencé fectivement qui précise les
terroristes ont subi des dommages
considérables en syrie où les forces
gouvernementales de contrôle selon lui
90% du territoire
ça semble
réaliste effectivement ce schiste c'est
le cas aujourd'hui alors c'est le cas
oui je sais pas si c'est 90% dans
l'incident l'homme dans la mesure où il
ya aussi la zone contrôlée par les
kurdes qui est toujours appuyé par les
américains les américains contrôlent
toujours la zone des puits de pétrole
donc là il ya une vraie un vrai enjeu
diplomatique un vrai enjeu international
les comment les djihadistes contrôlent
toujours la zone d'idlib ils sont
appuyés de façon indirecte par la
turquie qui en a fait une sorte de
commandes de protectorat on dira donc il
ya quand même encore beaucoup de monde
dans cette zone du nord les choses ne
sont pas absolument pas régler notamment
la question de dieu d'hayat aller al
cham qu'on l'ancien front elle nous sera
qui dirige littéralement cette province
d'idlib et qui sont des djihadistes même
si ces djihadistes eux à la différence
des talibans peut-être nom avait on
commet n'auront plus leur lien avec al
qaïda pour se faire bien voir on dira un
petit peu de la communauté
internationale mais non les choses ne
sont pas tout à fait réglé il ya eu une
insurrection qui est un peu passée à
comment sous le sous les feux de
l'actualité à cause de l'afghanistan
dans la ville de dera le problème
sécuritaire dans la ville de dera été
réglé une partie des combattants qui
s'étaient révoltés sont partis dans la
zone dite libre donc il ya eu à nouveau
une ville en insurrection en syrie donc
tout n'est pas réglé le problème de la
syrie ça a été évoqué mais la syrie est
sous sanctions internationales donc
c'est un pays qui a qui manquent de tout
dans lequel la population et dans est
tombé à un niveau de misère considérable
la livre syrienne ne vaut plus rien donc
il ya énormément énormément de problèmes
n'y a pas d'investissement syrie en a
trop peu on n'est pas à la phase de la
reconstruction il faudrait des milliards
de dollars est pour le moment le sait
milliards de dollars ne sont pas là donc
on a un bachar el-assad qui profitent
effectivement de cette tribune mais qui
aussi vient appuyer une sorte de
renaissance relative diplomatique dans
la région la crise au liban profite à la
syrie la crise grave non la spirale sans
fin dans laquelle et en étant fermé le
liban profite à la série puisque les
américains ont accepté la semaine
dernière qu'il y ait des livraisons
d'hydrocarbures depuis l'egypte en
traversant le territoire syrien depuis
la jordanie d'électricité depuis la
jordanie en traversant également le
territoire syrien ça c'est à l'étude
pour la première fois une délégation
libanaise la semaine dernière s'est
rendu à damas donc il ya une sorte de
retour dans le jeu diplomatique de
bachar al assad on sait que en 2018
également les émirats arabes unis
avaient réouvert leurs ambassades à
damas depuis on s'était on avait dit oui
aura d'autres ambassades qui vont
réouvrir ça n'a pas été le cas mais un
certain nombre de pays comme l'irak
notamment poussent pour que la syrie
rejoindre à nouveau la ligue arabe ce
qui a été une demande formulée donc si
vous voulez
bachar el-assad et dans toujours dans un
isolement diplomatique mais il est
relatif et il commence à se fissurer il
est évident que ce cet entretien à
moscou lui offre à nouveau une tribune
internationale
une manière de montrer qu'il est
toujours appuyé et c'est aussi une
manière pour vladimir poutine de montrer
que c'est toujours le maître du jeu en
syrie merci beaucoup régis le sommier
pour ce décryptage merci à vous